this was my boy
emmett till
i got a letter today from auntie lizzy
she said bo's been working the fields
i can't imagine oh he just doesn't
understand how different things are in
mississippi are you listening yes
be small down there
like this
never thought anything would happen to
him
[Music]
meet the mummy
[Music]
he just wanted to go on vacation and
have fun with his cousins
but if my son could just
get his feet back onto the chicago soil
he'd be one happy kid
i don't know why i said that
[Music]
i want to talk to you about that boy
they've come for you
[Music]
it's hard to describe what a mother
knows
the first thing i noticed when i became
a mother was that my hands were busy
all the time my hand knew him with my
eyes closed
just like i know his laughter in a
crowded room
it's the same thing
when you know all of someone
this was my boy
emmett till
the body of emmett lewis hill has been
found dead
can i at least just fix them up a bit no
they have to see it for themselves
you tell me maybe i was risking your
life gonna help
those pictures of your son
change people's lives
i can't look baby
we have to
the lynching of my son has shown me that
what happens to any of us anywhere in
the world
had better be the business of us all
you